bonsoir michel raimbault merci de
répondre à nos questions comment est-ce
que vous analysez les premières phrases
échangées tout à l'heure entre les deux
hommes face caméra sourires de façade ou
bien entendre réel
par écouter
parce qu'il
ya certaines banques à un sourire de
façade
ont négocié
que tout va bien même si ce n'est pas
parce qu'il vient enfin un sourire de
façade et puis peut-être garde himmich
présidente est rien en tout cas le fait
de parler de d'amorcé de faire des
détours de négociations ça peut pas
faire de mal d'un contexte de tension et
disent de nous prendre nos tellement à
trois entre la france et la russie
spécifiquement notre totale entre la
russie et est l'hôte al kader les états
unis avant tout et puis les européennes
cols blancs ni
censure donc c'est difficile de trouver
une position qui soit différente de
celle des états unis mais pour la france
je pense que pour le président macron il
ya un enjeu également nationale
puisqu'on est à deux mois des élections
présidentielles on ne sait pas si
finalement compte pas il sera
certainement mais l'apathie et puis là
il est le président de l'union
européenne et donc il s'agit pour lui en
quelque sorte comme l'on dit tels ou
tels observateurs que de se mettre au
dessus de la mêlée et de se donner une
posture de dirigeants européens est très
influent et qu'il peut mener la danse
papier européen
finalement et de façon plus ou moins
autonomes non moi je note que d'après ce
que l'on dit le président macron à
consulter de au moins deux chefs d'état
seulement sept homologues de chefs
d'état pas ils ne sont pas votre union
européenne l'avenir boris johnson
camille et puis le premier ministre
britannique et le président américain
joe biden alors ça je ne sais pas ce qu
a été changé est en tout cas une certain
que emmanuel macron par son porteur de
nous pas de message de la
grande-bretagne et des etats-unis mais
comme il a voulu se couvrir pour ne pas
faire cavaliers seuls sons sa
présidente
de cette réunion qui durera huit clos
depuis une heure et quart maintenant ce
que nous a dit tout à l'heure notre
notre correspondant en tonnes claireaux
parce que ce matin le porte parole du
kremlin dmitri peskov a parlé d'une
réunion je suis très importante mais
qu'il n'attendait pas de percée
significative
puis le président français a reconnu
dans l'avion présidentiel ne pas
attendre une solution à court terme donc
à quoi elle sert concrètement cette
cette réunion sachant qu'il ya un dîner
également un de travail ce soir on sait
que lors des dîners vous qui êtes ancien
ambassadeur s est là que les choses
peuvent se détendre
oui bon effectivement
même si on mange mais
crois pas que ce soit vraiment oui c'est
une étape obligée d'en en compte
mais je pense que pour le dire qu'il y
aura pas de percée il est heureux que
tout le monde soit d'accord là dessus
parce que le conflit est vraiment très
très aiguë c'est d'un compliqué pas
seulement occasionnels c'est un conflit
de fonds il remonte finalement à la
chute de l'union soviétique
et donc
l'engagement qu'avec des prix par le
président américain à l'époque et qui
n'a jamais été respecté qui a été violée
dès la 10 jours c'est à dire de le local
occident s'engager à ne pas faire un
seul pas en direction des anciennes non
seulement des anciennes démocraties
populaires mais également encore us id
anciens états membres de l'onu mairesse
or toutes ces promesses ont été violées
on a fait comme si elles n'existaient
pas parce que vous avez theora l'école
le président gorbatchev était
probablement un grand naïf quand même
disons le comme ça alors je crois que
seul le mail entendu est revenu ensuite
il ya une crise la crise d'ukraine
proprement dits d' n'oublions pas qu'on
ne peut pas on our n'a fait de la zapper
la réalité c'est pas né comme ça d'une
crise mais c'était quand même un coup
d'état qui a violé directement un
processus électoral qui entraîne et un
coup d'état qui malgré les engagements
pris notamment parce qu'ils ont été
parties à l'accord de minsk est
finalement à violer toute légalité en
faisant semblant de conseiller coli a
bien perçu les accords de mines ce que
soit respectée
par les accords de mise à kingston il
faudrait qu'ils soient respectés ne faut
pas trop espérer qu'ils le sont qu'ils
n'ont pas été jusqu'à présent donc en
réalité on ne reconnaît pas la situation
est l'origine de la situation et
lentement de la crise et composent
finalement la russie comme un agresseur
potentiel alors que la russie finalement
jusqu'à présent n'a pas de troupes dix
ans sur intérêts péri par d'autres une
truie ni aux frontières disons à des
milliers de kilomètres de chez elle
comme nous les américains je trouve que
l'occident et notamment les états unis
sont singulièrement complet de parler
d'agressivité de la russie alors ils ont
débat sur la planète entière notamment
que je dirais donc on a dans la région
et que lotader prêtons frontières de la
russie je crois que ce n'est pas fair
play il ça n'est pas de bonnet à la loi
croix gammées mélange dans les coûts
initiaux xi dental fait pas spécialement
de la commission française mais la
france partage cette double qualité de
l'ignorance historique et d'arrogance et
un peu inquiétante et donne même pas à
une bonne compréhension des problèmes et
quand elle devient en négociation selon
vous qu'est-ce qui pourrait être
annoncée aujourd'hui quel levier de
négociation point emmanuel macron idem
quel levier de négociation pour vladimir
poutine à la coûteuse je pense qu'il
pourrait annoncer que la colle la
négociation que les conversations vont
continuer et puis que peut-être que ça à
l'école que sans ça écarte rare un peu
au moins dans le temps la non-accession
six agressions il n'ya pas d'une
agression ne rentrent pas d'une tension
militaire parce que ce que l'on dit
auprès de l'agression je trouve que les
facteurs sont singulièrement quand même
à verser ont fait de l'agresseur lagacé
d'agréer l'agresseur je trouve que c'est
une pas même un peu inquiétant mais ça
faut pas espérer que l'occident changera
ni la france ni les états unis ni
l'autre européen ne changeront leur
position là-dessus ont délibérément les
plus pratiques de falsifier un petit peu
la réalité c'est un peu la technique
occidentale depuis des lustres
maintenant et donc de présenter les
agresseurs comme les agresser les
agresser comme les agresseurs alors je
crois pas dur à deux changements dans la
et si on peut éviter quand même une
guerre ça serait quand même pas si mal
que ça ne serait que ça sert qu'à ça se
servir à ça et pour pas se leurrer je
dirais le problème restera entier
puisque finalement les occidentaux y
compris aux manuels mâcon vient pour
essayer d'arracher qu'agent de sécurité
n'est garantie de sécurité auprès d'un
tiers alors que en ignorant totalement
au contraire les assurances de sécurité
qu'a demandé le président russe à ses
vis-à-vis occidentaux donc je pense
qu'avant pour une fois la compréhension
qu'est notre part merci michel raimbault
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes essayiste et
ancien ambassadeur de france